This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Ten years ago, Clementine Spilure moved to Paris, France. She was full of ideas of what her life could be. I just wanted to go to Paris. I didn't really want to study anymore. So I just packed a bag and moved to Paris, which is a pretty romantic movie-like kind of thing. So I guess I had this idea that you can you know you can make it in Paris you can you can just get there and then try to make it. Clementine was working for a wealthy family. She babysat their 11 year old twins, cooked dinner,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。十年前，克莱门蒂娜·斯皮卢尔搬到了法国巴黎。她对未来的生活充满了各种设想。我当时只想去巴黎。我其实不想再学习了。所以我只是收拾了一个行李箱就搬去了巴黎，这听起来是一件非常浪漫、像电影一样的事情。所以我想我当时有一种想法，你知道的，你可以在巴黎闯出名堂，你只要到了那里，然后去努力实现它就行了。克莱门蒂娜当时在一个富裕家庭工作。她负责照顾他们 11 岁的双胞胎，做晚餐，
and cleaned the bed. At the time I was Clementine's neighbor. That's producer Jean Boissec. She grew up near Nantes, a city on the west of France. Clementine stayed in the area during her undergrad, but then she wanted to see the big city. In France, Paris is the center of everything. In exchange, the family gave her an apartment to live in. There was an interview, and then we got out of the building and walked to another building that was like two, three
并打扫床铺。当时我是克莱门蒂娜的邻居。那是制作人让·布瓦塞克。她在南特附近长笛长大，那是法国西部的一座城市。克莱门蒂娜在读本科期间一直呆在那片地区，但后来她想去大城市看看。在巴黎，巴黎是一切的中心。作为交换，这家人给她提供了一间公寓居住。当时进行了一场面试，然后我们走出了那栋建筑，走到了另一栋建筑，大概有两、三
minutes away. Climbed the six floors. And then, yeah, she took me to the room and she was like, ta-da, that's it. Clementine stared into her new home and discovered it was really small. Actually, it was just one room. I sat on the bed. There was nowhere else to sit on. I sat on the bed. There was a tiny, tiny kitchen in the corner. There was a shower. There was a table that folded that I basically never used because if you
分钟的路程。爬了六层楼。然后，是的，她把我带到那个房间，然后她说，锵锵，就是这样。克莱门蒂娜凝视着她的新家，发现它真的非常小。事实上，它只有一个房间。我坐在床上。没有其他地方可以坐。我坐在床上。角落里有一个小得不能再小的厨房。有一个淋浴间。有一张可以折叠的桌子，我基本没用过，因为如果你
unfolded it, you couldn't walk. Basically, I think you could walk three steps in the room. From the door to the window is like a small corridor. In terms of width, it was like maybe like two meters wide. I remember when I was sitting on your bed, I could put my foot against the wall. It's a good thing you weren't, I was smaller than you were, because yeah. Clementine was living out a rite of passage for generations of young people moving to the French capital. Her place was a very specific, very Parisian type of apartment called a Chambre de Bon, literally a maid's room.
把它展开，你就没法走路了。基本上，我觉得你在房间里只能走三步。从门到窗户就像一条小走廊。就宽度而言，可能也就两米左右吧。我记得当我坐在你的床边时，我的脚可以碰到墙。好在你不——我比你个子小，所以是的。克莱门蒂娜正在经历一代又一代移居法国首都的年轻人必经的成年礼。她的住处是一种非常具体、非常具有巴黎特色的公寓，被称为“女佣房”（Chambre de Bonne），字面意思就是女佣的房间。
A Chambre de Bon is usually one small room on the top floor of a five or six story apartment building. I lived in a chambre de bonne down the hall from Clémentine, but my chambre de bonne was a little bigger. My apartment had two windows and my own bathroom, but it was still very small. I had a bathroom so narrow I could stretch out my arms and touch both walls at the same time. So these doors are doomed? Last October, Clémentine and I returned to our old building both walls at the same time.
女佣房通常是五到六层公寓楼顶层的一个小房间。我住在克莱门蒂娜走廊尽头的一个女佣房里，但我的女佣房要大一点。我的公寓有两个窗户和自己的浴室，但它依然非常小。我的浴室窄到我可以伸展双臂，同时摸到两扇墙。所以这些门注定要倒霉吗？去年十月，克莱门蒂娜和我重返我们旧日的建筑，同时摸到两扇墙。
Last October, Clementine and I returned to our old building for the first time in years to take a trip down memory lane. You know when I remember that the stairs on the last one are higher? Yes. And it's the moment when you run out of breath and you're like, I hate my life. And you have to keep going and it's even're gonna find it and then you can begin. Yeah, but I remember like climbing the stairs and seeing all the floors, they're so pretty.
去年十月，克莱门蒂娜和我多年来第一次重返我们旧日的建筑，开启了一趟重温旧梦之旅。你知道当我回想起来时，最后一段楼梯更高吗？是的。这就是你喘不上气的那一刻，你会想，我讨厌我的生活。而且你必须继续爬，而且更……你会找到它，然后你就可以开始了。是的，但我记得爬楼梯时看到所有的楼层，它们都那么漂亮。
Oh my God. Also, remember the old guy who got the far right newspaper. Yeah. Clémentine lived in her chambre de bonne for three years. Yeah, it looks smaller. It looks smaller. Or did we grow? At the time, Clémentine loved her apartment.
哦天哪。还有，还记得那个订右翼报纸的老头吗？是的。克莱门蒂娜在她的女佣房里住了三年。是的，它看起来更小了。它看起来更小了。还是我们长大了？当时，克莱门蒂娜非常喜欢她的公寓。
It was a way to make her dream of living in Paris a reality, even though her employer felt a little awkward about it. I remember she was like, kind of apologizing. She was kind of, sorry, that's it. I hope it works for you. And me, I was just like, wow, I want to be this person. Like, this is like, you're under the roofs in Paris. And it's my home.
这是一种将她住在巴黎的梦想变成现实的方式，尽管她的雇主对此感到有点尴尬。我记得她当时有点像是在道歉。她有点像说，抱歉，就是这样。希望这能适合你。而我当时只是想，哇，我想成为这样的人。就像是，你住在巴黎的屋顶下。这是我的家。
It's mine. Just like Clémentine, I loved my Chambre de Bonne. Our building was in Le Marais, a fancy neighborhood in the center of Paris, in a beautiful building hidden behind a big heavy green door and a pretty courtyard. But today, both of us see things very differently. It was kind of terrible to live in this place. I remember when I moved out, I felt how my mind was able to expand as well. It wasn't just physically.
它是我的。就像克莱门蒂娜一样，我也很喜欢我的女佣房。我们的建筑位于玛黑区，这是巴黎市中心的一个高档街区，坐落在一栋隐藏在大厚绿门和漂亮庭院后面的美丽建筑里。但今天，我们两个人的看法发生了很大的变化。住在这种地方简直糟糕透顶。我记得当我搬出去的时候，我感受到了我的思维也能够随之扩展了。这不仅仅是身体上的。
When I moved out, I realized that I hadn't had enough space to think. It's like the space was so small that you couldn't even get out of your own limitations mentally. It also impacts your ability to think forward and it really living in such a tiny space is always a reminder even if it's unconscious that you're only entitled to this tiny bit of space. Parisians like Clementine have difficult relationships with the Chambre de Bonne because it represents a lot of things. It's affordable housing in a city where finding housing is nearly impossible.
当我搬出去时，我意识到我以前没有足够的空间来思考。就好像空间太小了，以至于你在精神上也无法摆脱自身的局限。它还会影响你向前思考的能力，而且住在这样一个狭小的空间里，总是在提醒你——即使是无意识的——你只配拥有这么一小块空间。像克莱门蒂娜这样的巴黎人与女佣房有着复杂的关系，因为它代表了很多东西。它是住房极其难找的城市里的经济适用房。
But it's unpleasant for people who have to live there. And it represents the gap between the rich people in Paris and everyone else. And even now that I understand the class relationship and the fact that it was so small and it's pretty violent to make people live in such small spaces. Today, many people live in Chambre de Bonne apartments because there's not a lot of small,
但对不得不住在那里的人来说，它并不愉快。它还代表着巴黎富人与其他所有人之间的鸿沟。甚至到现在，当我理解了这种阶级关系，以及它如此狭小、让人们住在这么小的空间里其实相当暴力时。今天，很多人住在女佣房公寓里，因为这里没有多少小户型、
affordable housing in Paris. And the city is so dense, it's impossible to build new housing. So the Chambre de Bonne is an imperfect solution. But today, the Chambre de Bonne are disappearing. And many are wondering, where are those people going to live? The Chambres de Bonne was invented as a housing type during a major redesign of Paris in the 1850s. It was led by a man named Georges Eugène Haussmann, whose name I will pronounce the English way. In French, it's more like…
巴黎负担得起的住房。而且这座城市人口密度太高，根本不可能建造新的住房。所以女佣房是一个不完美的解决方案。但如今，女佣房正在消失。许多人在问，那些人将去哪里居住呢？女佣房是在 1850 年代巴黎大规模重新规划期间作为一种住房类型被发明出来的。它由一个名叫乔治·欧仁·奥斯曼（Georges Eugène Haussmann）的人领导，我将用英语发音来念他的名字。在法语中，它更像是……
George Eugène Haussmann. Yeah, I don't know how to say it that way. Anyway, Houseman was the prefect for Paris for 20 years. He was commissioned by Emperor Napoleon III to overhaul the city's architecture. Napoleon wanted Paris to be masterful and a capital of the world. To reflect these grand ambitions, Houseman created wide boulevards and avenues. A lot of people say, Haussmann made the bourgeoisie visible in Paris. He destroyed working class neighborhoods
乔治·欧仁·奥斯曼。是的，我不知道该怎么用那种发音说。总之，奥斯曼担任巴黎省长长达 20 年。他受皇帝拿破仑三世委托，全面整修城市的建筑。拿破仑希望巴黎能够展现大师风范，成为世界的首都。为了反映这些宏伟的野心，奥斯曼建造了宽阔的林荫大道和大街。很多人说，奥斯曼让资产阶级在巴黎显现了出来。他摧毁了工人阶级的社区，
and replaced them with luxury buildings. Paris was a mess of construction for 50 years. Workers from all over the country came to serve Haussmann's vision. Suddenly, in the streets of Paris, you could hear accents and songs sung by workers from all over France. They created some of Paris's most iconic landmarks, the Avenue de l'Opéra, the Boulevard Haussmann, the Boulevard Voltaire. But all this construction was at a cost. In some cases, Haussmann cut buildings in half to make room for new ones. Some people called him an artist demolisher. Haussmann only designed apartments because that's where everyone lived in Paris at the
取而代之的是豪华建筑。巴黎经历了长达 50 年的建设混乱。来自全国各地的工人们前来为奥斯曼的愿景效力。突然之间，在巴黎的街头，你能听到来自法国各地的工人们的口音和歌声。他们创造了巴黎最具标志性的地标，歌剧院大街、奥斯曼大道、伏尔泰大道。但所有这些建设都是有代价的。在某些情况下，奥斯曼将建筑物从中间切断，为新建筑腾出空间。有些人称他为“拆迁艺术家”。奥斯曼只设计公寓，因为当时巴黎的所有人都是住在公寓里的，
time. And he designed every apartment building to be the same, inside and out. That's Mary-Jeanne Dumont. She's an historian of architecture. Mary-Jeanne says in Haussmann's buildings, there was always one apartment per floor. And in those luxury buildings, the families expected to have rooms to house their servants. to have rooms to house their servants.
而且他把每栋公寓楼都设计得里外一致。那是玛丽-让娜·杜蒙（Mary-Jeanne Dumont）。她是一位建筑历史学家。玛丽-让娜说，在奥斯曼的建筑中，每层楼通常只有一套公寓。在那些豪华公寓里，家庭期望有房间来安置他们的仆人。有房间来安置他们的仆人。
In the 1850s, during the Houseman redesign of Paris, there was a large influx of young women moving to the city to work for the bourgeoisie. They came from poor regions like Brittany in the west of France. At the time, French regions were mostly rural, They came from poor regions like Brittany in the west of France. At the time, French regions were mostly rural, and coming to Paris was a way to find a job and send money to your family. All those people who came were quite young, 14 or 15 years old in many cases. Life was hard for these servants, and many of them were living inside their employers'
在 1850 年代奥斯曼重新规划巴黎期间，大批年轻人涌入这座城市，为资产阶级打工。他们来自法国西部布列塔尼等贫困地区。当时，法国的地区大多是农村，他们来自法国西部布列塔尼等贫困地区。当时，法国的地区大多是农村，而来到巴黎是寻找工作并把钱寄回家的途径。所有这些来这里的人都相当年轻，在很多情况下只有 14 或 15 岁。这些仆人的生活很艰难，他们中的许多人住在雇主的
apartments, which made them available to work 24 hours a day with very few breaks. In 19th century France, it was common for rich French people to wake up their servants in the middle of the night for small annoying tasks like fetching a glass of water. The work ruined many of these young workers, who returned home after life in Paris, exhausted and demoralized. Marie-Jeanne is explaining that before the Chambre de Bonne, in the 18th century, servants lived in areas above the kitchen or the stables. Chambermaids would sleep in tiny rooms near the employer's bedroom, very small rooms, usually with no window.
公寓里，这使得他们能够全天 24 小时随时待命工作，却几乎没有什么休息时间。在 19 世纪的法国，富有的人在半夜叫醒仆人做一些琐碎烦人的杂事（比如去倒杯水）是很常见的事。繁重的工作毁掉了许多年轻工人，他们在巴黎生活一段时间后，精疲力竭、士气低落地回到了家乡。玛丽-让娜解释说，在女佣房出现之前，即 18 世纪，仆人们住在厨房或马厩上方的区域。女佣们会睡在雇主卧室附近的小房间里，非常小的房间，通常没有窗户。
But the Hausmann redesign changed that. The construction of the bedroom is also linked to a constructive system. Marie-Jean says, before Hausmann, Paris apartment buildings had small, triangle roofs made of zinc. There was not a lot of room to install an attic under the roofs, but Hausmann's redesign included a series of sloped, mansard roofs. The mansard roofs were sweeping and dramatic. They were a popular design.
但奥斯曼的重新规划改变了这一点。卧室的建造也与一种建筑系统有关。玛丽-让娜说，在奥斯曼之前，巴黎的公寓楼有着用锌做的小三角屋顶。屋顶下没有多少空间可以安装阁楼，但奥斯曼的改造包含了一系列倾斜的芒萨德屋顶（Mansard roof）。芒萨德屋顶宽阔而引人注目。它们是一种很受欢迎的设计。
But Haussmann created these sloped roofs because of something very mundane. Municipal height restrictions. At the time, Paris had a height limit on new buildings. Every building could only be 65 feet tall. But that height limit wasn't for the very top of the building, it was for the cornice line where the roof begins. So the mansard roof is kind of like cheating, it allowed the building to be taller without violating city laws.
但奥斯曼之所以建造这些斜屋顶，是因为一个非常世俗的原因。市政高度限制。当时，巴黎对新建筑有限高规定。每栋建筑的高度只能达到 65 英尺。但这个高度限制并不是针对建筑的最顶部，而是针对屋顶开始的檐口线。所以芒萨德屋顶有点像是在“作弊”，它允许建筑建得更高，而不会违反城市法律。
Now the very top floors were all big triangles, and they could put big attics under there. These triangle attics weren't desirable for the bourgeoisie living in Paris. You could not rent it out like the rest of the apartment. But the bourgeoisie decided that they would pay a little extra money for the space and put their servants up there. That's how the idea of the Chambre de Bon was born. Instead of living with their employers, now maids and servants could live in a private space above them.
现在，最顶层的楼层都是大三角形，他们可以在下面搭建大的阁楼。对于住在巴黎的资产阶级来说，这些三角形阁楼并不受欢迎。你没法像房子的其他部分那样把它租出去。但资产阶级决定为这个空间多付一点钱，把他们的仆人安排在上面。女佣房的概念就是这样诞生的。女佣和仆人们不再与雇主同住，而是可以住在他们上方的私人空间里。
I visited a typical, classic chambre de bonne with Marie-Jeanne Dumont. This apartment is in the 11th arrondissement, right near La Place de la République. We are in a very small, typical Bonne chamber. It was lit up by a small window. Mary-Jeanne is telling me that this chamber de Bonne was pretty typical of its era. It was lit up by a small window. The space is very well preserved. It actually looks like it came straight from the 19th century. The Chambres de Bonne, by definition, are not very big,
我与玛丽-让娜·杜蒙一起参观了一间典型、经典的女佣房。这间公寓位于第 11 区，就在共和国广场附近。我们身处一个非常小、非常典型的好女佣房间里。一个小窗户将房间照亮。玛丽-让娜告诉我，这间女佣房在那个时代非常典型。一个小窗户将房间照亮。这个空间保存得非常好。它看起来确实像是直接从 19 世纪搬过来的。女佣房按定义来说都不是很大，
especially at a time when the expectations were very small. So architects had to make the most of every square foot of space. This old-style Chambres de Bonne is a lot smaller than the one I lived in. Based on Hausmann's designs, the original Chambre de Bonne were usually about 75 square feet. You could barely fit a bed in there. It was typical for these rooms to have one iron bed, a small table, a chair, and a small piece of furniture to store things.
尤其是在当时人们对空间的期望非常小的时候。因此建筑师必须充分利用空间的每一平方英尺。这种老式的女佣房比我住的那间要小得多。根据奥斯曼的设计，最初的女佣房通常只有大约 75 平方英尺（约 7 平方米）。里面勉强塞得下一张床。这些房间里通常只有一张铁床、一张小桌子、一把椅子和一个用来存放物品的小柜子。
There was no water inside. The only bathrooms or sinks were in the hallway. The early chambres de bonnes were not well maintained by the rich people. Some bourgeois didn't even change the sheets when they hired new employees. Life was awful up there. Domestic workers would die because there was no ventilation. At the beginning of the 20th century, Parisians became very concerned about tuberculosis. They started to believe that the Chambord-a-Bons were so filthy,
里面没有水源。唯一的浴室或水槽都在走廊里。早期的女佣房并没有被富人们好好维护。有些资产阶级甚至在雇佣新员工时都不换床单。那上面的生活糟透了。家政工人们会因为没有通风而死亡。在 20 世纪初，巴黎人对结核病变得非常担忧。他们开始相信，女佣房是如此肮脏，
they made workers sick, and that the maids brought the diseases into their employers' home. So the very first Chambord-a-Bons were abandoned, and employers moved servants into slightly bigger rooms. This wasn't because they wanted better living conditions, but because they were afraid of the disease. But the new chambordobans were still really small, and the problems continued. Things didn't change much until the early 20th century. During World War I, women were authorized to work in factories for the first time, and
以至于让工人们生病了，而且女佣们把疾病带到了雇主的家里。因此，最早的女佣房被废弃了，雇主们把仆人搬到了稍微大一点的房间里。这不是因为他们想要更好的生活条件，而是因为他们害怕疾病。但新的女佣房依然非常小，问题仍在继续。直到 20 世纪初，情况才发生太大变化。第一次世界大战期间，女性首次被允许在工厂工作，而
being a servant became a lot less appealing. The factory jobs had a proper salary, and women preferred them even if the work was more intense. to work as a domestic worker in a bourgeois family. And so bourgeoisie called it the domesticity crisis. Marie-Jeanne explains that bourgeois called this the domesticity crisis. It was harder in many ways to work at a factory, but young people thought it was better than being a servant. So there was nobody available to do things like cooking and cleaning. With this labor shortage, there was a available to do things like cooking and cleaning.
做仆人变得不那么吸引人了。工厂工作有固定的薪水，即使工作更繁重，女性也更愿意选择工厂。去资产阶级家庭做家政工。因此，资产阶级称之为“家政危机”。玛丽-让娜解释说，资产阶级称之为家政危机。在许多方面，在工厂工作更辛苦，但年轻人认为这比当仆人要好。因此没有人来做诸如做饭和打扫卫生之类的事情了。随着这种劳动力短缺，去做诸如做饭和打扫卫生之类事情的人手短缺。
With this labor shortage, there was a pressure on rich people to make the Chambres de Bond more livable, and French politicians at the time were passing labor laws creating more rights for workers. In 1904, a law was passed. Now all apartments had to be 86 square feet. The old closet-sized Chamb de bont weren't allowed anymore. The new apartments were still just about 9 feet by 9 feet, but it was an improvement. Slowly, the chambre de bonts got even better.
随着这种劳动力短缺，富人们面临着让女佣房变得更宜居的压力，当时的法国政客们正在通过劳动法，为工人创造更多权利。1904年，一项法律通过了。现在所有的公寓都必须达到 86 平方英尺。过去那种衣柜大小的女佣房不再被允许了。新公寓虽然仍然只有大约 9 英尺乘 9 英尺，但已经是一种改进了。慢慢地，女佣房变得越来越好。
Landlords added windows and more toilets in the hallway, and after World War II, France developed a middle class. By mid-century, it wasn't servants and domestic workers moving to Paris to live in the Champs-Élysées. Now it was a popular housing type for students and young people coming to the city for the first time, and they had higher expectations. But it was not until 2002 that France passed another law to make apartments bigger. The new law said no one should live under 97 square feet out of decency. In 100 years, Parisians only gained a few feet of space.
房东们增加了窗户和更多的走廊厕所，二战后，法国发展出了中产阶级。到了世纪中期，来巴黎住在香榭丽舍大街的不再是仆人和家政工人，而是成为学生和初次来到这座城市的年轻人的热门住房类型，他们的期望更高了。但直到 2002 年，法国才通过了另一项旨在扩大公寓面积的法律。新法律规定，出于体面考虑，任何人的居住面积都不应低于 97 平方英尺。在 100 年里，巴黎人只多争取到了几英尺的空间。
Many of the existing chambre de ban apartments were no longer in compliance. So many landlords decided to demolish the walls between two or three chambre de ban to make a single, larger apartment. This rule has led to a lot of Chambres de Bonne being combined, and that has created some very strange apartment layouts. My name is Manisha, I'm 22 years old. I've been living in Paris for a year and living in this Chambre de Bonne for 10 months, and I work in a publishing house. I wanted to meet up with Monisha because she lives in one of the new style Chambres de
许多现有的女佣房公寓不再合规。因此，许多房东决定拆除两到三间女佣房之间的墙壁，将其合并为一间面积更大的公寓。这条规定导致许多女佣房被合并，这也创造了一些非常奇怪的公寓户型。我叫马尼莎（Manisha），今年 22 岁。我在巴黎住了一年，在这间女佣房里住了 10 个月，我在一家出版社工作。我想见见马尼莎，因为她住在新式女佣房里。
Bonne. Her apartment is 150 square feet, it's on the seventh floor of a building in the 11th arrondissement, and it's very obviously two apartments that were smashed together. So this is your house? It is. In my flat, more than a house. So tell me a bit about it. So we're in the first room? Yeah, well, there's only one room, but it's separated by a wall, I guess. In the middle of the apartment, there is a wall with no door.
她的公寓面积为 150 平方英尺，位于第 11 区一栋建筑的七楼，很明显是由两套公寓打通合并而成的。所以这是你的家？是的。在我的公寓里，比一个家还……所以跟我讲讲它吧。所以我们现在在第一个房间？嗯，其实只有一个房间，但它被一堵墙隔开了，我想。在公寓的中间，有一堵没有门的墙。
That wall separates the bedroom-bathroom area from the kitchen-dining room area. So this is the kitchen. There's a small table, two chairs. Here I have my clothes because there's not a lot of storage... And it's right behind the door. Yes, so you cannot fully open the door, but that's okay. And there's a window. Yes. Manisha doesn't like her apartment very much.
这堵墙将卧室兼浴室区域与厨房兼餐厅区域隔开。所以这是厨房。有一张小桌子，两把椅子。这里有我的衣服，因为储物空间不多……而且它就在门后面。是的，所以你不能完全把门打开，但没关系。这里有个窗户。是的。马尼莎不是很喜欢她的公寓。
She was living in a bigger place in Lyon, in the south of France, where she studied. This place she's living in now is small, it's imperfect, but she can afford it. There are so many people looking. The flats, as soon as an ad is posted, it's like gone. Yeah, there's a lot of demand. The Chambord-Auban is still an important part of the housing ecosystem. The average rent for a one-bedroom in this neighborhood is 1400 euros, or about $1500 per month. This apartment costs about one-third of that, and since Manisha is making the French minimum
她以前住在法国南部里昂一个更大的地方，她在那里上学。她现在住的这个地方很小，并不完美，但她负担得起。有太多人在找房了。这些公寓，一旦发布广告，就像凭空消失了一样。是的，需求量很大。女佣房仍然是住房生态系统的重要组成部分。这个街区一居室的平均租金是 1400 欧元，也就是每月大约 1500 美元。这间公寓的费用大约是那个的三分之一，而且由于马尼莎拿的是法国最低
wage, it still takes up about 40% of her salary. In some ways, Manisha is lucky. Because our situation, a young person with little income renting a cheap Chambre de Bon is becoming rare across the city. Against all odds, the Chambre de Bon is becoming a valuable commodity. The price to rent a Chambre de Bon has been going up in recent years. There are a couple of reasons for this, including the newfound popularity of elevators in Paris apartment buildings. According to Marie-Jeanne Dumont, the elevator has changed who is living on the top floor of buildings.
工资，它仍然占去了她大约 40% 的薪水。在某些方面，马尼莎算是幸运的。因为我们的情况——一个收入不高的年轻人租一间便宜的女佣房——在整个城市正变得越来越少见。出乎意料的是，女佣房正在成为一种有价值的商品。近年来，女佣房的租金一直在上涨。这有几个原因，包括电梯在巴黎公寓楼中的新流行。根据玛丽-让娜·杜蒙的说法，电梯改变了住在建筑顶层的人。
With the invention of the elevator, poor people and domestic workers started to move down to the first floor, closer to street noise, and rich people moved up to the penthouse suite. This was a common phenomenon around the world. But Paris was pretty late to the party. When I lived in a Chambre de Bonne, it was very strange for an Haussmann building in Paris to have an elevator. You had to climb sixth or seventh floor to get to your small apartment. But more and more, landlords have installed elevators
随着电梯的发明，穷人和家政工人开始搬到一楼，离街头噪音更近，而富人则搬到了顶层豪华套房。这是世界各地的一个普遍现象。但巴黎在这方面相当滞后。当我住在女佣房时，巴黎的一栋奥斯曼建筑里有电梯是一件非常奇怪的事。你必须爬六层或七层楼才能到达你的小公寓。但越来越多的房东在全城安装了电梯。
across the city. Back in October, Clementine and me were shocked to discover an elevator, we actually say, an ascenseur, in our old building. There's an ascenseur! Oh! Oh! That's funny.
早在去年十月，克莱门蒂娜和我震惊地发现我们的旧建筑里居然有一个电梯，我们其实管它叫“ascenseur”。有一个 ascenseur！哦！哦！太好笑了。
So, here, on the other hand, there's a fucking elevator! For those of you who don't speak French, Jean and Clementine are, you know, let's say disappointed that the landlord waited until after was no room for an elevator, voilà, a beautiful new ascenseur. It probably explains why our old places are more expensive today. I left in 2016. When we talked to the new tenant, I was surprised to learn the rent had gone up. The Chambre Bon is becoming more expensive, but it's also beginning to disappear as a housing type in Paris.
所以，这里，另一方面，居然有一个他妈的电梯！对于你们这些不会说法语的人来说，让和克莱门蒂娜，你知道的，可以说是对房东一直等到没有空间安装电梯才装电梯感到失望，瞧，一个美丽的新 ascenseur。这大概解释了为什么我们以前的地方今天更贵了。我在 2016 年离开的。当我们与新租客交谈时，我很惊讶地得知租金上涨了。女佣房变得越来越贵，但作为巴黎的一种住房类型，它也开始逐渐消失。
In 1968, there were 66,000 people living in Chambre de Bon apartments in the city. According to the most recent public data, that number is down to just over 17,000. The disappearance of Chambre de Bon is striking. A big reason for this is people with money taking old Chambre de Bonne and renovating them. In fact, today, wealthy Parisians will buy up a whole floor of Chambre de Bonne apartments and make them into one big living space. The apartments have gone from cramped living quarters
1968 年，这座城市有 66,000 人住在女佣房公寓里。根据最新的公开数据，这个数字已经下降到略多于 17,000 人。女佣房的消失令人震惊。这其中很大一部分原因是手头宽裕的人买下旧的女佣房并对其进行翻新。事实上，今天，富有的巴黎人会买下一整层的女佣房公寓，将它们合并成一个大的起居空间。这些公寓已经从
for poor people to some of the most valuable real estate in Paris. Is that where you were when Notre Dame burned down? We didn't see it. I was in the apartment. You didn't see it? valuable real estate in Paris. This is Guillaume. Years ago, he did one of these renovations. He is 50 years old and he lives in the 5th arrondissement, right near the Place Saint-Michel. It's a very fancy part of town. You can actually see Notre Dame through the window of his living room, which is pretty unusual in Paris. Nobody has that kind of view.
穷人的逼仄住所变成了巴黎最珍贵的房地产之一。那是巴黎圣母院着火时你在的地方吗？我们没看到。我在公寓里。你没看见？巴黎最珍贵的房地产。这是纪尧姆（Guillaume）。多年前，他做过这样的翻新。他今年 50 岁，住在第五区，就在圣米歇尔广场附近。这是城里非常高档的一个地方。你实际上可以透过他客厅的窗户看到巴黎圣母院，这在巴黎相当罕见。没有人能拥有这种视野。
One of my ancestors built this building, and in exchange for his work and participation in the reconstruction of Paris, he was paid in real estate. That's how the bourgeoisie I'm from was created. The wealth is entirely rooted in real estate. This building has been in my family for 150 years. The memory I have of people who worked for my parents and who were housed here, the domestic workers did the groceries, cooked, everything. They lived and worked here full-time.
我的祖先之一建造了这座建筑，作为他工作和参与巴黎重建的报酬，他获得了房地产。我所在的资产阶级就是这样产生的。这份财富完全扎根于房地产。这座建筑在我们家族已经有 150 年了。我对那些为我父母工作并住在这里的人有记忆，家政工人们去买菜、做饭，包办一切。他们全职在这里生活和工作。
When Guillaume's mother died a couple of years ago, his father passed down all the real estate to their kids. One apartment went to Guillaume's sister, and the top floor, which contains the servants Chambre de Bon was given to Guillaume. It was the beginning of the 2000s, and Guillaume decided not to rent out the old Chambre de Bonne.
几年前纪尧姆的母亲去世后，他的父亲将所有的房地产传给了孩子们。一套公寓归了纪尧姆的姐姐，而包含仆人女佣房的顶层则给了纪尧姆。那是 2000 年代初，纪尧姆决定不把旧的女佣房租出去。
Instead, he kept it and did a big renovation to make one apartment for his family. By knocking down walls and extensive reconstruction work, Guillaume and his wife took seven Chambre de Bonne and made one big, beautiful living space. You may have mixed feelings about this. It sounds bad during a housing crisis to take seven rooms and make one big apartment. But to Guillaume, those rooms just couldn't be used as apartments anymore.
相反，他保留了它并进行了大规模翻新，为他的家庭打造了一套公寓。通过推倒墙壁和广泛的重建工作，纪尧姆和他的妻子将七间女佣房改造成了一个宽敞、美丽的起居空间。你可能对这种做法百感交集。在住房危机期间，把七个房间改成一套大公寓，听起来似乎不太好。但对纪尧姆来说，那些房间实在无法再当作公寓使用了。
I think it was more like an obvious decision. It was a pretty obvious decision. These little walls, they weren't usable for an apartment. They were really tiny. Well, there were squat toilets with a water tap that went into a tub, so I was obliged to change the layout. It wasn't usable. And besides, he needed somewhere to live with his growing family.
我觉得这更像是一个显而易见的决定。这是一个相当显而易见的决定。这些小墙壁，它们不适合用来做公寓。它们真的太小了。嗯，那里有蹲便器，水龙头通到一个浴缸里，所以我不得不改变布局。它没法用。此外，他需要一个地方和不断扩大的家庭一起生活。
Today, Guillaume has four kids, and finding a place for a family of six is virtually impossible in Paris. Renovations like Guillaume's are becoming more common across Paris. In many cases, these renovations take a small, cramped apartment and make them livable. But this kind of renovation has also reduced a valuable source of affordable housing. Ultimately, it's not up to people like Guillaume to preserve affordable Chambord-a-Bont apartments. That's a problem for the decision-makers at City Hall.
如今，纪尧姆有四个孩子，在巴黎为六口之家找个地方几乎是不可能的。像纪尧姆这样的翻新在巴黎各地变得越来越普遍。在许多情况下，这些翻新把一个小而逼仄的公寓变得宜居。但也正是这种翻新，减少了经济适用房这一宝贵资源的来源。归根结底，保护平价女佣房不应该是像纪尧姆这样的人的责任。这是市政厅决策者们的问题。
Paris is a city that is majorly a city of... Yann Brossard is a senator from the Communist Party. He just got elected last September. But before that, he was a deputy mayor in Paris, working specifically on housing for nine years. He says that Paris is a city of tenants, and most Parisians are concerned about rent. Brossard says the rent in Paris is too high. He says when families grow, they can no longer afford to live here because they cannot afford
巴黎主要是一座……扬·布罗萨（Yann Brossard）是来自共产党的一名参议员。他刚在去年九月当选。但在此之前，他是巴黎的副市长，专门负责住房工作达九年之久。他说巴黎是一座租房者的城市，大多数巴黎人都对租金感到担忧。布罗萨说巴黎的租金太高了。他说，当家庭扩大时，他们再也负担不起住在这里的费用，因为他们租不起
to rent a bigger place. Yann Brossa says Paris is one of the most densely populated cities in Europe, so there isn't much opportunity to build new housing. The city is already too built up. Paris is a dense and historic city, where it's actually illegal to construct high-rise buildings. So Paris can't just build a lot of tall apartments. And with the lack of housing stock, the prices keep going up.
更大的房子。扬·布罗萨说，巴黎是欧洲人口密度最高的城市之一，因此没有太多建造新住房的机会。这座城市已经过度开发了。巴黎是一座密度极高且历史悠久的城市，在这里建造高层建筑实际上是违法的。所以巴黎不能凭空建造许多高层公寓。由于住房存量不足，价格不断上涨。
Brossard says his team made some progress on housing when he was deputy mayor. They managed to get the amount of social housing in the city up to 25 percent. But the city is still facing a major lack of affordable housing. The Chambre de Bonne could be a useful solution for this, because many of them are vacant. According to the most recent data I could find, 85 percent of the Chambres de Bonne in Paris are vacant. This is largely because of the law passed in 2002 to guarantee a minimum apartment size. Many Chambres de Bonne are just too small to be lived in. Jean Brosson says that the Chambres de Bonne could be a breeding ground for new housing
布罗萨说，当他担任副市长时，他的团队在住房方面取得了一些进展。他们设法将城市中社会保障住房（廉租房）的比例提高到了 25%。但该市仍然面临着严重的经济适用房短缺问题。女佣房可能是解决这个问题的一个有效方案，因为其中许多都处于空置状态。根据我能找到的最新数据，巴黎 85% 的女佣房都是空置的。这在很大程度上是因为 2002 年通过的保证公寓最低面积的法律。许多女佣房实在太小，无法住人。让·布罗松说，女佣房可以成为这座城市新住房的温床。
in the city. Obviously, these apartments have to be combined, but Brossard says there is great housing potential under Parisian roofs. There's a potential under the roofs that should be better exploited. When I first moved to my Chambre de Bonne, I remember how big it felt.
显然，这些公寓必须合并，但布罗萨说巴黎屋顶下蕴藏着巨大的住房潜力。屋顶下确实有应当被更好开发的潜力。当我第一次搬进我的女佣房时，我记得它感觉是那么大。
My dad was here to help me, and one of his first comments was how small it was given the rent. I could not see it. I was too happy to move to Paris. I was doing my first internship in public radio. To me, apartments are more than just a place we live in. They are also a place where we make memories. I always remember the sound of Clementine's lock in the morning when she left her room, and the text we used to send each other at the end of the day, I'm downstairs, do you need anything? So that the other one doesn't have to climb all the stairs a second time in the day.
我爸爸来帮我，他的第一句评论之一就是，考虑到租金，它实在是太小了。我当时根本看不出来。我太高兴能搬到巴黎了。我当时在公共广播做第一次实习。对我来说，公寓不仅仅是我们居住的地方。它们也是我们创造回忆的地方。我总是记得克莱门蒂娜早晨离开房间时锁门的声音，以及我们在一天结束时发给我的短信：我在楼下了，你需要什么吗？这样另一个人就不用在一天里第二次爬所有的楼梯了。
When I moved out, two years later, I got sad. Clementine took a picture of me sitting on the floor in the empty room covered in sweat after moving all my stuff. More than saying goodbye to my apartment, I was saying goodbye to this part of my life. And Clementine had the same experience when she moved out. Some friends came to help me move out, and one of my friends who'd never been here looked at my empty room and was like, you lived here the three years? And we just stood there and I had never looked at the room that way and I think because I was leaving I finally could look at it and be like,
两年后我搬走时，我变得很难过。克莱门蒂娜拍下了我坐在空房间地板上的照片，搬完所有东西后我浑身是汗。与其说是向我的公寓告别，不如说我是向我人生中的这一段经历告别。克莱门蒂娜搬家时也有同样的经历。一些朋友来帮我搬家，我一个从没来这里的朋友看着我空荡荡的房间说，你在这儿住了三年？我们就站在那儿，我从来没有那样看过那个房间，我想因为我要离开了，我终于可以看着它并觉得，
I had to be in a lot of denial to be able to have a daily life in such a tiny space. It's barely made to sleep at night inside of it, but I was having a very normal life. I would have friends over. So yeah, I understand why it's easy to get nostalgic about the Chambre de Bonne. But maybe it's time to retire this type of housing and find a better solution for Parisians. One thing is clear, if the Chambre de Bonne disappears forever, we need to find something to replace it. When we come back in many places, the entrance to Jean Bourbon apartments are hidden and only accessible by a special set
我必须极力否认现实，才能在这么小的空间里过上日常生活。它里面勉强只够晚上睡觉，但我过着非常正常的生活。我会请朋友来家里。所以，是的，我理解为什么人们很容易对女佣房产生怀旧之情。但也许是时候让这种类型的住房退役，为巴黎人找到更好的解决方案了。有一点是明确的，如果女佣房永远消失了，我们需要找到东西来替代它。当我们回来时，在很多地方，让·布尔本公寓的入口是隐藏的，只能通过一组特殊的楼梯才能进入。
of stairs. More with Jean Boisac after this. So we're back with Jean Boisac. Hey Jean. Hi. So in this episode, we talked about your ordeal of climbing six flights of stairs to get to your Jean Bourbon. But something we didn't get to in the episode is this idea of service stairs. Can you explain
稍后将带来更多关于让·布瓦萨克的内容。我们又和让·布瓦萨克在一起了。嘿，让。嗨。所以在这一集里，我们讨论了你为了到达让·布尔本公寓而爬六层楼梯的磨难。但我们在这一集中没有涉及的一点是服务楼梯的概念。你能给我解释一下
service stairs to me? So service stairs are most of the time hidden and they are how many people get into their Chambre de Bon apartments. The service stairs connect the Chambre de Bonne to the first floor. So it's not the main stair that you use. So to understand this, first we need to talk about private mansions in Paris. So before Haussmann, most bourgeois who lived in Paris live in Hôtel Particulier, which are private mansions. You can still see examples of this in Paris. For example, the Musée Carnavalet,
服务楼梯吗？所以服务楼梯大部分时间都是隐藏的，它们是许多人进入让·布尔本公寓的方式。服务楼梯将让·布尔本公寓连接到一楼。所以它不是你用的主楼梯。所以要理解这一点，首先我们需要谈谈巴黎的私人宅邸。因此在奥斯曼之前，大多数住在巴黎的资产阶级都住在“私人府邸”（Hôtel Particulier）里，也就是私人宅邸。你仍然可以在巴黎看到这样的例子。例如，卡纳瓦莱博物馆（Musée Carnavalet），
the museum of the city of Paris. It used to be an Hôtel Particulier. So in these mansions, they had separate staircases for servants. And they had the opportunity to separate where the people who live there actually go in and where the servants go in and go out. And it was separated.
巴黎市的博物馆。它过去就是一座私人府邸。所以在这些宅邸里，他们为仆人准备了单独的楼梯。他们有机会将住在那里的日常人员的进出路线与仆人的进出路线隔离开来。并且它们是分开的。
They use the front door and servants the back door, just to be clear. And then Haussmann comes along and we get all these apartments for the bourgeois. And in many cases, they retain the idea of the service stairs. It's connected by the kitchen. And the idea was all the ugly stuff leaves the apartment by those stairs. So groceries, coal, trash, and the servants. We don't see them. And they would still have a separate staircase for the people living in the Chambre de Bonne. Actually service stairs were the only stairs going all the way up to the Chambre de Bonne.
他们走前门，仆人走后门，说清楚点。然后奥斯曼来了，我们有了所有这些供资产阶级居住的公寓。在许多情况下，他们保留了服务楼梯的概念。它通过厨房连接。这里的想法是，所有难看的杂物都通过这些楼梯离开公寓。比如杂货、煤炭、垃圾，还有仆人。我们看不到他们。而且他们会为住在女佣房的人保留一个单独的楼梯。事实上，服务楼梯是唯一一直延伸到女佣房的楼梯。
The main one wouldn't go all the way there. Just for you to have a better understanding of the difference between the main stairs that was used by the bourgeois and the service stairs that was used by the servants, like to imagine it, you need to think about an Haussmann building and the stairs. Like we always talk about the stairs in Haussmann buildings, they have a nice red carpet and it's super nice. Well, when you think about the service stairs, it's the opposite. It's very narrow, very small.
主楼梯不会一直通到那里。为了让你更好地理解资产阶级使用的主要楼梯和仆人使用的服务楼梯之间的区别，要在脑海中想象它，你需要想到奥斯曼建筑和楼梯。就像我们经常谈论奥斯曼建筑里的楼梯一样，它们铺着漂亮的红地毯，超级漂亮。嗯，当你想到服务楼梯时，正好相反。它非常狭窄，非常小。
It's just stairs, one point to another point. And so how do they work? How do you get to the service stairs inside of a houseman apartment? You think about like an houseman building and There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它只是从一个点通往另一个点的楼梯。那么它们是如何运作的呢？你怎么进入奥斯曼公寓内部的服务楼梯呢？你想想奥斯曼建筑和……本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。